strategy wise okay Trump the Santa so
for you you're you're thinking there's a
part of this that there is weaponizing
of the justice system against the former
president perfect then then that that's
been that's been a while that goes back
to when they fixed Hillary Clinton case
then I then I have a question for you
because I think you're partially
responsible and and so here's where I'm
going with this and let's see what
direction you're going to take this so
we pulled up five historical facts about
weaponization federal government of
course we can go back to McCarthyism
where the you know communism they're
going against that 40s 50s we've all
know about that one then you have the
coin cointel Pro from 1956 to 71 the FBI
ran a covert operation known as
cointelpro which aimed to disrupt and
discredit various political groups
including civil rights activists and
type this is the Malcolm X this is the
Martin Luther King then you have the War
on Drugs 80s and 90s they launched this
that led to a sharp increase in the
number of people incarcerated for drug
offenses then we have the Patriot Act
and prior to that you know we have the
RICO which you know the gentleman Blakey
who was a I think Notre Dame professor
in 1970 he came up with that and then
you guys kind of found a way on how to
go after the mob and then boom you took
down pretty much clean up the streets of
New York with the mob everybody was
trying to figure out a way to do it you
were the only one that ended up being
successful
you got the Patriot Act in 2001 which
the government passed this which
explained the government's ability to
surveil and investigate suspected
terrorists critics argued that the laws
has been used to infringe on the civil
liberties of innocent Americans that it
has been used to Target individuals and
organizations based on their political
views rather than their actual links to
terrorism and then you have the Mueller
investigation which happened in 2017. so
partially when you're doing this at the
beginning I'm assuming this is purely uh
speculating I'm assuming you're like hey
guys we got to take down the mob and
clean up the streets of New York we got
to do it no problem fantastic how are we
going to do it this guy comes in from
Notre Dame let me tell you this is one
thing that we came up with the
racketeering to recoact all this other
stuff let's do it then the government
said wow what a great weapon to use
against the people and then that got
stronger and more creative and then some
evil leaders got their hands on and
saying we can silence people how awesome
was this so even though original it was
used
to take the bad people out now it's
being used to hurt good and innocent
people how going back would you say
partially the RICO some of these things
you guys that do you regret any of it
making it as strong as it ended up being
that we're experiencing what we're
experiencing today well first of all I
don't know if all all of them are
related the same thing uh the difference
between then and now is every one of
those uh began as a legitimate uh issue
involving our national security our
safety they weren't nobody passed a
Patriot Act to go after innocent people
I mean this what's going on right now
was designed for one purpose and one
purpose alone for the ruling party to
take out the opposition party that had
no legitimate purpose at all the
weaponization of the justice department
was not to go after Mafia guys
terrorists people who kill you the
webization of the justice department was
such destroy a well really any
opposition to the to the regime
secondly any any law
can be misused there's I mean you can
miss you can misuse a
a minor misdemeanor
uh and weaponize it for filing false
entries in your books
so you're always subject to that your
subject the laws are there
uh it's like saying the Soviet Union had
a constitution
the red China has a constitution with
more right than our Bill of Rights
considerably more
but it doesn't mean anything so I don't
know that I don't know that the
government
even being excessive in pursuing bad
guys
and maybe even being a little bit
overzealous in doing that I don't think
that leads to what is now uh typical of
a totalitarian regime which is the
ruling party
using the criminal process to go after
the opposition party I think that's a
totally different thing and I think it
developed in a in a different way
I think it developed because of the
long-term influence of the Communist
party on the Democratic party and I
think they've basically taken over I
think this is a well thought out plot
that goes back at least 20 or 30 years
to destroy our government and I think
that's why Soros is funding it why does
Soros pay for 40 or 50 DA's all over the
country to basically destroy these
cities
because Soros wants our government to
fall
he wants a One World Government
he probably wants to run the One World
Government or at least be the head of
the Department of the treasury
so he can steal from it and uh so no I
don't really I don't regret the RICO
statute I think the RICO statute it
would be excellent to use for example
against the Biden crime family it'd be
probably exactly the whole idea of the
racketeering Act is
you just can't put them in jail you got
to take their property away
because if you just keep putting the
mafia in jail some other mafia guy comes
along and takes over the five billion
dollar Enterprise and it becomes 6
billion and it was a recognition by
Professor Blakey who I knew very very
well that the only way we're going to
crush the mafia is to take their empire
away for example one of the cases that
isn't mentioned that I did was I took
the uh changes Union away from the mob
which meant taking Las Vegas away from
the map because they controlled Las
Vegas to the central State's pension
fund
of the Teamsters Union
you thought it was a central State's
pension fund money it was the mafia
money that was being laundered for 30
years
um so I no I don't I don't regret it
what I do regret is the wrong people
getting in government and then being
able to use any of these laws but but we
can't but but we know the wrong people
are eventually going to be in power
right so
you certain policies could work for good
people
because a good person may not abuse the
power that they have but you have to be
thinking about policies to create that
an evil guy doesn't come and say I want
to abuse my power so you know I
understand what you're saying it was
built for the good guy to you know find
and catch the bad guy but what if the
bad guy is now the leader that's going
after the good guy so what could we have
done differently the only reason I'm
asking this question is because we
gotten out this fed Now app coming out
we got cbdc coming out we got this
restrict act coming out that they're
saying oh we're going to take down Tick
Tock and Charlie Kirk made a very good
point the other day the fact that
they're using this to say they want to
silence Dave Rubin Dave we're sorry we
don't like the message you got we got to
go after him so so only thing I'm asking
is I'm not a lawyer I didn't work in the
New York you know District as an
attorney you've been around the block
for the next people the next Giuliani
the next guy that's going to have that
kind of a power when they're writing
these acts up should they do it or don't
even do it don't even go there but if
they do do it what what how do you write
to make sure Bad Guy cannot weaponize it
bad guys can weaponize anything
they can weaponize the simplest law or a
complex law and you can't deprive
yourself of laws that are going to
protect you against murderers rapists
terrorists you can't um
you can't pass a law that can't be uh
misused by by a bad guy if a bad guy
gets into into power
uh it is this is not a question of the
laws that we passed it's a question of
the people that we voted for like uh the
people of Chicago
they've got to be something wrong with
them voting for the person they voted
Lori Lightfoot
he's talking about Johnson there's got
to be something wrong with him they're
brainwashed
um
this this is a this is a development
that happened within politics rather
than within the the legal system because
even if we didn't have these laws and
most of these laws weren't even used by
the Democrats in weaponizing the Justice
Department they're much simpler laws
that they used or they make things up
the the indictment of trump is a
non-existent indictment it's a it's
known void it doesn't charge a crime
it charges a crime without explaining
the crime which would lead to the
dismissal of any other indictment the
judge should have dismissed should have
thrown it out as known void I don't know
why his lawyers didn't get up and
refused to plead to it if I represented
him he never would have pledged to that
indictment I would have said this is not
an indictment it says here this was in
pursuance of a crime what would you like
me to do guess which one of the 1 000
New York crimes it is would you give me
a hint at least
what am I pleading to
if you read the indictment you don't
know what you're pleading to he's
pleading he if he pled guilty you
wouldn't know what you pled guilty to
so what do we can't do away with
indictments but we got to do is do away
with corrupt District Attorneys like
Alvin Bragg I mean that's that's the
problem
Dave what do you think well let me add
something to to slightly defend the
mayor from the time that he was in
office and beforehand when he was uh
when he was dealing with the mafia and
all of this stuff when these laws were
put into place you know we used to have
Democrats and Republicans that disagreed
on on certain issues meaning taxation
certain things related to Crime certain
things related to abortion etc etc but
there wasn't one party that in essence
was solely existing to pretty much
destroy America as we know it and become
completely Lawless and not know the
difference between boys and girls and
want neo-racism taught in the schools
and not believe that jailing criminals
is correct Etc et cetera we now have one
party like that so I think what's
happening now you got a guy like Alvin
Bragg who we were discussing it at
dinner the guy does not uh charge you
with the crime if you jump the Turn
Style in New York city so think what
you're doing you're doing two things
when you do that first off you're
incentivizing people for bad behavior
right you're telling them go ahead and
jump the turns style do whatever you
want and you're also telling the
law-abiding person in New York City
you're a sucker man you're paying your
250 or 275 whatever it is on the subway
now while while these kids are just
jumping over they will not prosecute for
prostitution the craziest one that they
will not process prosecute for is uh is
avoiding arrest so you are allowed to
literally fight the cop as he's trying
to arrest you and you will not be
penalized for that so I think what's
happened here there's a little asymmetry
most of us especially if you live in a
free state a Law and Order State like
Florida where by the way we are now
getting all of the good cops you know
that there were there were thousands and
thousands of incredible members of the
New York Police Department who are now
moving down here DeSantis is giving them
bonuses and we're becoming stronger and
they're becoming weaker the difference
is that when you have one side that is
completely unhinged related to law and
reality
there is no law that you can set up that
will not be abused so I'm going to still
push back if you're okay with that guy
yeah and I want both of you guys to try
to rip apart my argument and I'm very
comfortable with that okay so you have
kids you have a family you're doing
estate planning you're doing living
trust okay and you would like to pass
down your wealth to your kids but you
would like them to manage the wealth in
a responsible way so it can go to your
grandkids and great grandkids and stay
within the family right so when you
study generational wealth and you go to
Rothschild you go to Rockefellers you go
to Vanderbilts you go to Medici family
all of these guys you will see
Vanderbilts were so flipping wealthy but
his living trust sucked yeah I think he
had like 11 kids within one generation
or two boom all the money was gone
medicis kept it in the family I think
Seven Generations Rockefellers kept in
the family three generations I believe I
believe the way we create the laws we
can say let's not vote bad people in
here but okay can you be a great parent
and have one of your kids that meets a
teacher at UC Berkeley and flips them
and all of a sudden they become a person
that cannot agree with anything you're
saying in your evil parent and all this
other stuff and if you give that guy the
money he's gonna go give the money to so
all I'm saying is we can't control evil
people we can't control people that get
influenced to do dumb things okay we
cannot control it even great parents
could have bad kids all I'm saying is
it's easy for us to put it all on Alvin
Braggs but he was able to do this
because certain things in the past you
can go and say well in this case here's
what it is so guess what the way they
took this guy down let's just go and
Target Donald Trump the way they took
this guy down all I'm saying is while
we're going through a big decision right
now with this restrict act you're not
going to be affected by it you and I
will be affected by it but our kids will
be affected by it because they're going
to be the ones that's going to be used
on social media a lot longer than we are
so we can sit here and be like well it's
not really ad we just got to make sure
we vote the right people in if it's all
about just voting the right people in
why are so many immigrants in America
they escape that I think there's a part
of it all I'm asking is mayor from you
and I want to transition to another
topic what can we learn from the way we
wrote these things up to not do it do it
again well maybe I didn't make it I
didn't I didn't point out this other
part of it I'm not saying there aren't
very bad laws and that laws are passed
that infringe human rights civil rights
are are too intrusive are unwise
can actually be more easily abused that
all happens and we shouldn't do that now
or before or later
I just don't think there's the
connection between that and what you're
saying I don't think Alvin Bragg exists
because let's let's say you believe that
the Patriot Act was overzealous intruded
too much into privacy and it might very
well I might agree with you on some of
that
um I don't think that's the reason we
are where we are today I think
independently we should fix it and
that's another problem that we have and
I think to restrict Act
I think it would be a very bad law and
it would be a particularly bad law
because our government has become more
corrupt
so we would be in the hands of corrupt
people but it shouldn't even be in the
hands of honest people and I think the
way we like I think the inheritance tax
is inherently
an inequitable unfair uh
anti-capitalism
anti-incensives to to to develop wealth
anti-human nature one of the reasons you
work hard is for your family
and then that's a contribution to
everyone because you're working hard
your main objective is your family but
you're helping society and doing that
and knowing that your wealth is going to
get cut in half or more
that's going to change it's going to
change that and then people are also
going to look for ways to break the law
these intrusive laws lead to a lot of
like if you have taxes that are too high
people find ways to avoid it and then
people find ways to evade it so I think
Patrick there are two I think there are
two different problems that you're
you're talking about
and I think the problem I think this
problem emerges from our politics
or morality or lack thereof
and I I do think and I know it sounds
like it this is a conspiracy theory that
I'm asserting but I am
it is a conspiracy
I think that China has a lot to do with
it
I think China has corrupted many of
these people who are involved in these
uh
unbelievably illegal applications of the
law
if uh if Biden isn't corrupted by China
it would be totally ridiculous the guy
got 31 million plus dollars in the last
six years from China
and he's taken actions for China that
that only could be taken by somebody
that seems to favor China over the
United States he gives up an air base
400 miles from China
that's insane
in an era in which we may be in a in a
war involving missiles and airplanes
being 400 miles from China is an
unbelievable
strategic advantage
given away by our president for nothing
in return
ah
is it a coincidence that the man who did
it
family got 31 million dollars from China
in the last six years no it's not a
coincidence you have to be ridiculous to
think it's a coincidence
he refuses to pursue China and the other
cause of covet
he refuses to
he told us that
China China really is a friend
ultimately a friend he's never said a
harsh word about China
day by day they're gaining an advantage
over us if they're not already
have an advantage that's going to take
them to what to their goal of being the
dominant Nation on on the Earth by 2048
I think that they'll get there faster so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]